that's not believed nation I want to
talk about judgment and inoculating
yourself against judgment so many of the
times the things that you want to do in
your life in your business you're afraid
because of somebody else's opinion
you're just afraid of how you're gonna
be seen how you're gonna be treated if I
put this at what's this person gonna say
one of my facebook friends gonna say
what's my what am i I G friends gonna
say what my parents gonna say and that
mentality is a losing game like you are
afraid to do the thing that you want to
do because of how somebody else is gonna
think that mentality is a losing game
you're set up to lose for life you need
to break out of it and so whatever the
thing is that you're afraid to do think
of something like it starts today think
of something that you're afraid to do
not not afraid of like you're afraid of
snakes and so go hold the snake although
that has its own benefits but the
judgments specifically fear of judgment
what are you afraid to be judged for
what are you fraid of doing in front of
somebody and then find a small way to go
do that thing because there's no way
you're gonna go off and build a huge
business and build an amazing life for
yourself if you're afraid of doing one
little thing in front of somebody else
also if you want to know what I think
and what other successful entrepreneurs
think about building confidence check
out my new to 54 confidence series where
every day for the next 254 days for free
I will send you a 30 second to five
minute video in the morning to help you
build unstoppable confidence the link is
in the description below if you want to
be more confident you need to surround
yourself with things that make you feel
confident realizing that any big
endeavor is the collection of a lot of
small steps that came before if you're
doing work that you loved you're more
likely to follow through you're more
likely to do it because it doesn't feel
like work because you love doing it if
you had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be like a little beacon if
you want to learn how to have ultimate
confidence and stop caring what people
around you think Chuck is a video right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there
poorni what other people call you okay
people call you a motivational speaker
Thank You Man I'm motivated you it's a
gift don't get shot by their labels